je voudrais qu'on essaye de se projeter
dans dix ans à quoi ressemblera le monde
en 2030 de ce qu'on sait aujourd'hui de
ce qu'on arrive à imaginer des
connaissances qu'on a aujourd'hui dans
la tête ou est-ce qu'on en sera un de
mes 30 je sais pas si vous avez une idée
sur ce sujet mais c'est justement que ce
dont je voulais parler avec vous essayer
de se projeter au regard de nos
connaissances alors on a regardé sur
différents points j'ai noté en tout je
crois 10 points 12 points exactement
pour essayer d'entrapercevoir le monde
dans dix ans 12 ans à quelque chose près
qu'on se projette tout de suite en 2030
et puis d'ailleurs si ce format vous
intéresse dites le moi on bat en
commentaires ou pour essayer de se
projeter en 2040 est plus dur en 2050
aussi dans une autre vidéo on pourrait
sur plusieurs vidéos plus on va regarder
loin et plus ce sera dur mais déjà en
une vision qui est assez intéressante de
ce qui pourrait arriver en 2030 même si
elle sombrera pas parfait touché en tout
cas
[Musique]
parce que si on regarde en arrière il
s'en est passé des choses revenons en
2010 2010-2020 2020 2022 à quelque chose
près ce n'est pas c'est vachement de
choses c'était le début du smartphone le
premier iphone c'est 2007 c'est vraiment
très très proche on était à la kadji
c'était le début de la 4g bref vous
voyez qu'en dix ans et s'est passé
vachement de choses est que plus le
temps avance et plus une accélération
technologique plus ça va vite plus il ya
des connaissances qui arrivent et plus
passe de choses une évolution des
réseaux sociaux il ya eu l'ubs et
risation s'est passé tellement de choses
que je me dis que dans les dix
prochaines années pour arriver jusqu'à à
peu près 2030 il va se passer tout
autant de choses voire beaucoup plus
alors on va regarder le tout premier
point tout de suite c'est ce que
j'appellerais l'homme réparer versus
l'homme améliorée et ben oui ça nous
vient surtout d'une news qui vient
d'elon musk et son entreprise ne ralink
alors si vous connaissez le buzz vous
savez qu'il ya tesla vous savez qu'il ya
space x mais il ya également de rallye
qui fait de la recherche au niveau du
cerveau pour venir réparer l'humain mais
également pour venir augmenter l'humain
alors bien souvent deux écoles qui
s'affrontent une version plus européenne
qui cherchent à venir réparer mais pas
augmenté mais il y aussi une version
assez américaine qui cherche à augmenter
l'humain à lui apporter de nouvelles
possibilités et c'est un peu ce qui pour
arriver potentiellement avec novalink
alors ça c'est l'aude mais ce qui nous
le montre si vous regardez on est sur le
site capital.fr est bien nos ralink la
start-up d'elon musk recrute pour tester
son implant cérébral mais on parle ici
de le tester sur l'humain alors on va
passer très très rapidement l'article
mais nous montrent qu'ils sont en train
de créer un poste directeur d'essais
cliniques qui cherchera à venir tu es
une équipe à aller voir les autorités
publiques tout ça pour aller tester des
implants sur l'humain donc on voit
qu'effectivement elle aurait cherché
d'abord à réparer l'humain mais ensuite
à augmenter et accélérer l'humain alors
si ça vous intéresse je vous invite à
aller voir ces articles qui sont super
intéressant et qu'on peut lire dans
capital.fr là c'est pareil voyez nous
prince article de l'année dernière john
muth de placer des micros plus au
cerveau des humains dès 2022 alors à la
base ça devait être dès 2021 ça être en
2022 les premiers tests donc on imagine
très bien qu'en 2030 ça sera fait ça
fonctionnera donc on pourra réparer
l'humain les gens qui sont en fauteuil
pourront re marché peut-être avec lui
j'en sais rien moi un exosquelette je ne
sais pas en tout cas il va se passer des
choses ça fait vachement intéressant et
puis l'idée qui est derrière tout ça
c'est effectivement j'irai de rendre le
monde plus compétitif vis-à-vis des
intelligences artificielles mais ça donc
ce futur quand même assez lointain pour
nous apporter des capacités de calcul
supplémentaire est en fait faire de nous
des des super humain des surhumains
peut-être même des duels et savard on
sépare déjà croire en dieu c'est un
autre débat je ne pense pas qu'on fasse
une vidéo là dessus mais en tout cas
pourquoi pas donc voyez il va se passer
des choses de ce côté là et un lob de
2030 on imagine qu'on va pouvoir réparer
de l'humain et qu'on va pouvoir
également l'augmenter après avoir toutes
les discussions et x on pourra retrouver
derrière le deuxième point qui va être
extrêmement intéressant et sur laquelle
la taxe va venir se positionner c'est
tout ce qui va être santé santé
prédictive aujourd'hui ce qu'on a dans
la santé c'est la santé curative
c'est-à-dire c'est de la santé vous êtes
malade et ensuite on vient vous apporter
des soins de santé oms vient vous
soigner ses de la santé curative mais ce
qui est important et tout l'enjeu de la
santé c'est de venir vous soigner de
venir changer des choses avant qu'une
maladie se déclare donc avant que vous
soyez malade parce que ce qu'il faut
bien comprendre c'est que entre le
moment où une maladie commence à arriver
un moment où vous vous en rendez compte
s'est passé des choses et c'est dans ce
laps de temps là et bien que viendrait
intervenir la santé prédictive alors ça
pour arriver de différentes manières on
le voit déjà on l'a des capteurs
démontre il faut montrer vous permettre
de faire quoi et bien de venir voir par
exemple si vous avez une arythmie s'il
ya des problèmes dans le sommeil enfin
bref permet de voir pas mal de choses et
monitorer mais on va pas assez loin et
haut pour aller plus loin au travers et
bien pour imaginer des miroirs connectés
or ça existe déjà un peu mais on irait
beaucoup plus loin on pourrait venir
mesurer votre taux de glycémie mais pas
uniquement des personnes diabétiques de
tout le monde pour venir prévenir
justement un problème de diabète pour
pourrait prendre plusieurs constantes de
votre corps qui vous permettrait de
savoir il ya qu'est-ce qui va qu'est ce
qui ne va pas quels sont les trous
potentiels qui pourraient arriver assez
rapidement pour ensuite vous proposez et
bien soin de réajuster une alimentation
pour rééquilibrer tout ça soit de faire
des exercices dédié pour vous aider à
améliorer ça et pourquoi pas être en
lien avec les médecins enfin bref on
pourrait imaginer un système
d'abonnement ou vous aurez accès un des
techniciens spécialisés s'il a embarqué
un truc qui marche pas pas vous avez
votre rendez vous enfin bref voilà c'est
un truc qui pourrait être intéressant
qui pourrait permettre effectivement de
prédire des infarctus prédire des avc
c'est toute une prédiction au niveau des
risques de cancer donc bref c'est un
sujet qui est vachement intéressante sur
lesquels de nombreuses entreprises
travailler ça permettrait à terme
d'avoir effectivement un vieillissement
de la population mondiale mais en bonne
santé en bonne santé on vivrait plus
vieux on vivrait mieux en bonne santé on
irradie créé des maladies ça serait cool
aussi mais ça c'est grâce à la tech
alors ce domaine au troisième point bien
c'est la tech médicale on voit qu'on
pourrait éradiquer des maladies avant
qu'elles apparaissent mais il y en a qui
passera au travers des mailles du filet
ou qu'on n'arriverait pas à voir malgré
ce système de monitoring et bien on
arriverait et on le voit notamment entre
à d'une technologie qui est extrêmement
intéressante à nantes on parle beaucoup
et technologie de la rn message est ce
un article que j'ai vue sur le monde un
article du président de bio ntech vous
savez qui est asocial finder pour son
vaccin contre une colonne 19 il
s'appelle ursa in et ce monsieur à dire
tous très intéressants c'est
qu'effectivement la rn message et c'est
pas une techno qui permettra uniquement
d'apporter des vaccins mais d'aller
beaucoup plus loin sur de la lutte pour
des virus notamment le vih notamment la
tuberculose et qui servira également en
médecine pour notamment venir ciblé pas
mal de problèmes liés au système
immunitaire parce que vous allez pouvoir
avoir une réponse immunitaire ciblée est
en plus totalement individualisé on peut
imaginer dans certains cancers ou vous
avez des traitements qui sont un peu
large et qui viennent cibler une zone là
vous soit quelque chose d'extrêmement
personnalisé pour notre pathologie pour
vous ça éviterait de tirer largement
d'être vraiment extrêmement précis au
niveau du curatif donc on voit que la
tête même si effectivement ces de la
biotech et bien nous permettra d'aller
plus loin pour soigner des maladies et
ça à l'horizon 2030 il le dit dans cette
interview il travaille dessus il faut
quand même pas mal de recherches il faut
du temps il faut des moyens donc ça va
arriver pas ici pas tout de suite mais à
l'horizon 2030 j'imagine qu'on aura un
panel de maladies qu'on arrivera à
soigner alors que tout de suite on n'y
arrive toujours pas ou très mal timbale
fera plus précis plus quatrième fois que
les super intéressant c'est une
connectivité les mains libres on va
venir se parler ici de le fait de
pouvoir déplacer dans la rue et lorsque
vous recherchez aujourd'hui votre chemin
vous faites quoi vous preniez votre
smartphone et vous regardez alors j'en
suis où line vite tourner à droite vous
tournez à gauche c'est bien mais c'est
relou parce que vous avez un truc dans
les mains alors on peut le faire
également avec des écouteurs connectés
tourner à droite rue truc ok mais là on
va faire avec des lunettes réalité
augmentée alors ça existe déjà
aujourd'hui mais c'est pas extrêmement
bien abouti c'est pas parfait ce ne
s'est pas complètement grand public ça
sera complètement grand public dans
quelques années à l'horizon 2030 ça
arrivera et là je vous parle de lunettes
mais pourquoi pas de l'anti les
entreprises de l'ateq travaille
également sur des lentilles connectés
j'ai testé des lunettes connectés c'est
un prototype de tcl j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir les essayer pour se rendre
compte un peu à quoi ça pourrait
ressembler alors c'était parfait c'était
un proto la question software n'était
pas complètement parfaitement bien
intégrés mais ce qu'on voyait
effectivement bien c'est un menu on peut
naviguer avec votre monture fin bref il
peut se passer pas mal de choses ça va
ouvrir beaucoup d'usagers si on se
projette un peu plus haut lieu d'abord
juste une navigation gps avec des
flèches à droite à gauche qui paraît
être un peu basique on pourra aller
beaucoup plus loin par exemple vous
sauriez à proximité d'une boutique on
vous dirait 21 ya des promos dans cette
boutique la s'afficherait sur vos
lunettes et non pas une au tiff sur un
smartphone voyez tout un système
également de géolocalisation qui serait
beaucoup plus précis pertinent au
travers de vos lunettes en réalité
augmentée par vous voyez les bacs sont
une boutique up tda promo votre regard
est là la promo elle reste là vous la
voyez et c'est vachement personnel c'est
vachement intéressant et si vous vous
rapprochez vous aurez plus d'infos sur
un côté de vos lunettes pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas vous pourriez lire vos sms
également en marchant vous pourriez par
exemple si vous vous approchez d'une
boutique et bien voir qu'ils ont le
stock d'un produit vous avez dans votre
wii liste peu de temps avant et que vous
voulez acheter bref ça ça a un sens ça
peut être intéressant si c'est bien
utiliser mais c'est évident que de
nombreux constructeurs travaillent sur
la réalité augmentée que ce soit par le
biais de lunettes ou par le biais de
lentilles voir les deux allez savoir ça
nous emmène ce point là nous emmène sur
le cinquième point la question du
metaverse avec vos lunettes vous et
pouvoir effectivement vous connecter et
si vous arrivez dans une boutique par
exemple et bien voir des choses qui
seront en réalité augmentée par rapport
à ce que vous voyez dans la boutique en
physique vous approché par exemple d'un
flacon de parfum et bien dans vos
lunettes vous auriez toutes les
informations ça pourrait vous permettre
je sais pas moi d'imaginer les senteurs
vous allez pouvoir ressortir proposer
des combinaisons vous afficher la liste
des ingrédients sans venir toucher le
packaging avec bref on pourrait imaginer
beaucoup de choses de la même manière
vous voyez un vêtement qu'il vous
intéresser bien lui il arrive à savoir
quels vêtements c et il va vous dire ok
dans ce vêtement il a été fabriqué à tel
endroit un vol à skis la polluer ou pas
pour arriver jusqu'ici à combien il faut
le laver bref pourrait avoir plein
d'informations extrêmement pertinente
son devoir lire une petite étiquette sur
laquelle on va globalement pas grand
chose donc on pourra aller beaucoup plus
loin et là je vous parle de réalité
augmentée mais on va aller plus loin
dans le métavers ce parce que c'est ce
qui montre est effectivement avec aussi
un proto de thé ciel vous mettez ensuite
mettre un cash soit vos lunettes en
réalité augmentée il avoue passer en
réalité virtuelle donc là vous arrivez
dans la boutique en ligne dans le
métavers ce qui sera en fait une
interface au lieu d'avoir un site web
sur votre ordinateur vous naviguez vous
êtes sur votre site menu vous n'aviez
bla bla bla bla non là vous arrivez dans
un environnement totalement virtuel
adapté à l'immersion que vous permet la
réalité virtuelle donc vous pourrez
allez faire votre shopping de la même
manière et ensuite recevoir les produits
directement chez vous vous pourrez avoir
des informations vous pourriez également
avoir votre propre maison dans le
métavers pour propre univers dans lequel
vous auriez des objets que vous auriez
acquis ou des choses que vous voulez
voir retourner voir plus tard une
galerie de vidéos qui vous intéressent
un concert dans une salle de spectacle
bref beaucoup de choses et ça c'est un
truc qui va arriver aussi alors c'est en
tout cas l'un des possibles d'internet
une évolution majeure qui me permettra
d'être plus immergé dans le web et non
pas juste d'avoir une petite interface
que soit un pc ou un smartphone et ont
piloté tout ça en se baladant dans la
rue par exemple temps dans un endroit
lambda à la commande vocale mais si vous
vous retrouvez par exemple dans les
transports en commun et qui a beaucoup
de bruit et bien vous allez faire quoi
vous allez prendre votre montre qui sera
également votre interface de smartphone
vous pourrez venir déplier votre écran
est tapoter directement sur votre monde
qui vous servira de claviers d'interface
ça peut être intéressant ça veut dire
que potentiellement on pourra voir non
pas un smartphone mais des lunettes qui
vous servira d'interface smartphone
interface écran et d'une montre pour
venir apporter des choses à voir il la
même manière chez vous vous pourriez
avoir des gants avec un touché à petit
pour venir sentir les choses que vous
touchez dans le métavers si j'en ai vu
la démo à las vegas je ne sais pas si
c'est une des solutions qui sera retenu
à l'avenir mais en tout cas c'est pas
mal on voyait des personnes qui
touchaient un chat qu'il le sentait
qu'ils touchaient un concert de dj qui
mixe est qu'ils sentaient des choses qui
nous amène au sixième point c'est la
vraie révolution de la crypto monnaies
et des mft ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que la blocs shane tournera fond
c'est à dire que lorsque vous serez dans
un environnement totalement
dématérialisé dans le métavers si vous
pourriez soit faire du shopping en ligne
avec le système de paiement un peu
standard au travers de votre banque vous
pourriez le faire que vous pourriez très
bien avoir des crypto monnaie pays avec
des cryptes monnaie et qu'il y ait une
transaction directement sans passer par
une banque est bien évidemment fausse
grand contrôle derrière donc pourquoi
pas tout ce que vous allez acheter dans
un univers virtuel x qui vous servira
pour votre maison virtuelle ou des jeux
virtuels auquel vous pourrez jouer grâce
aux metaverse on peut imaginer ça
également comme ça puisque semble aussi
être un des avenirs du jeu vidéo
l'immersion la vr verra ça bien
évidemment et bien tout ce que vous
achèteriez vous aurez des titres de
propriété en effe t ça ça pourrait être
intéressant également alors là on parle
de la maison parlent effectivement de se
balader dans la rue mais qu'est ce qui
va se passer du côté de l'automobile
passer le septième pointé comme sa
septième fois et bien l'automobile on va
voir la voiture autonome enfin ça y est
la voiture autonome et ici elle arrive
ça veut dire vous avez plus passé par me
conduire ça sert à rien que vous allez
pas la conduire votre voiture elle va
être autonome elle va se gérer
automatiquement tout seul alors il y
aura deux grandes possibilités au niveau
de l'automobile soit vous allez pouvoir
vous même acheté votre voiture comme
vous faites aujourd'hui est ensuite
votre voiture vous guidera d'un point a
à un point b pour aller au boulot pour
aller voir des amis pour partir en
vacances soit va y avoir une vraie
démocratisation du carsharing du fait de
partager de l'automobile vous n'allez
pas forcément vous achetez l'automobile
vous pourrez prendre une automobile en
location dans la rue comme on va pouvoir
venir louer un vélo ou etc soit le louer
directement auprès d'un loueur soit
quelqu'un qui a sa propre voiture et
qu'il la met en location moment où ces
personnes ne l'utilisent pas pour venir
vous l'apprendre et allez faire vos
courses à des coûts ce que vous voulez
donc ça rendra les routes beaucoup plus
sûr puisque il n'y aura pas d'accident
liés à des erreurs humaines en tout cas
ça rendra les personnes qui veulent se
déplacer qui aujourd'hui ont des
problèmes d'autonomie bien d'être plus
autonomes ce qu'ils n'auront plus à
conduire il ya pas mal de bénéfices
derrière et sur le papier ça c'est
intéressant ça nous emmène au huitième
point qui est l'évolution de la 5g et
l'émergence de la cij et qu'est ce qui
va se passer lorsque vous serez avec vos
lunettes connectés en réalité augmentée
dans la rue eh bien elles vont venir se
connecter à des objets non loin de là on
peut imaginer se connecter par ailleurs
comme je vous le disais à un produit que
vous allez avoir sous les yeux et avoir
toutes les informations sur ce produit
là grâce à de l'a5 jacques des ondes
millimétriques
c'est à dire des ondes de courte
distance permettra également un vrai
sort de l'automobile autonomes les
voitures on pourra revenir communiquer
entre elles grâce à de la 5g communiquer
avec un feu rouge grâce à la 5g
communiquer avec je sais pas quoi moi
une information des travaux sur le côté
grâce à de la 5g y aura un vrai maillage
de tous les objets connectés grâce à la
5g alors avec plusieurs types de 5 g
mais globalement ce sera de la 5g
imaginer par exemple vous êtes avec vos
lunettes toujours en réalité augmentée
vous vous approchez d'une école et hop
là vous voyez quel menu qui apparaît ici
alors vous regardez vous voyez le menu
voyez les informations vous dis pas
tiens une info personnalisé pour vos
enfants dans leur classe et bien cette
semaine il se passe ça ça ça et ça et
lorsque vous partez l'école et bien
l'info allait rester là bas vous pouvez
la voir également votre espace numérique
connecté mais lorsque vous rapprocher le
lieu vous avez des infos vous allez
pareil vous à la comptine votre boulot
hop on vous dit ce qu'a mangé vous
approchez d'un resto pas vous voyez la
carte directement dans vos lunettes vous
avez pas besoin d'attendre que la
personne devant se décale du menu pour
pouvoir le voir bref on accès à plein
d'infos pour y avoir le talent reste os
qu'il est plein est ce qu'il est plein
celui-là non au oui non on aura accès à
toutes ces informations en temps réel
grâce à la 5g ça ça peut être super cool
et si on pousse la réflexion beaucoup
plus loin vous verrez que les usages y
sont presque fini et c'est vraiment là
où la 5g va être intéressante au lieu
d'avoir aujourd'hui des débits plus
rapides et la latence plus faible on
aura vraiment cette interconnexion de
tous les objets jusqu'à un moment on
risque d'arriver un petit peu à
saturation il va falloir que la cij et
arrive en renfort pour venir vous
proposer d'autres plages de fréquences
avec probablement des ondes encore plus
courte mais ça c'est une autre histoire
et on le verra effectivement en 2030
parce qu'aujourd'hui on n'arrive pas à
le savoir le neuvième point et bien
c'est effectivement on le voit un vrai
changement dans les villes un vrai
changement pourquoi parce que les gens
vont chercher en 2030 à privilégier la
qualité de vie plutôt qu'à se trouver un
job vachement bien avec une heure de
transport alors c'est pas le cas tout le
monde en france et dans le monde entier
mais si vous prenez la question des
mégalopoles où les grandes villes comme
paris où vous devez faire une heure
trajet encore une heure je suis millions
pour aller bosser une heure à l'est une
retour voir des fois deux heures à les
deux heures retour ça c'est juste plus
possible donc il va y avoir un vrai
changement de l'organisation des villes
à savoir qu'effectivement vous n'allez
pas forcément travailler de chez vous
parce que c'est quand même bien de
sentir chez soi mais vous n'allez pas
nécessairement aller à votre boulot qui
est beaucoup trop loin on aurait donc
des espèces des espaces de coworking de
bureaux auxquels vous pourriez vous
allez travailler auquel votre entreprise
viendrait payer un loyer et vous vous
connecterez liés à votre boîte via un
vpn tout serait extrêmement sécurisé et
vous pourriez travailler non loin de
chez vous mais toujours en sortant de
chez vous dire une nouvelle organisation
de la vie dans les villes les villes ou
même peut-être pas que les villes
permettrait de travailler de n'importe
où quelle que soit votre endroit sur la
planète dès lors vous arriveriez à
communiquer avec différents fuseaux
horaires ça pourrait être réalisé sans
problème et puis autre chose qui va
arriver c'est l'émergence de la
robotique c'est le dixième point on le
voit aujourd'hui les robots commencent à
arriver on voit que les robots ça a
marché on voit que les robots commence à
communiquer on voit que les robots
peuvent bouger des bras on voit qu'ils
peuvent même courir sauter pas faire pas
mal de choses il faut encore un petit
peu de travail pour que on arrive à des
usages grand public au niveau de la
robotique mais en 2030 il y aura une
émergence de la robotique grand public
où on n'aura pas juste un petit
aspirateur robot qui fait son boulot et
qui terminera on aura un robot
multifonction pas nécessairement
extrêmement intelligent mais extrêmement
compétent qui viendra quoi et bien qui
viendra ranger votre maison tiendra la
mettre en ordre qui viendra installer la
tap qui pourra débarrasser des choses
qui rendra des services cohérents qui
pourra venir monter un escalier le
descente qui sera là pour vous chez vous
dans l usage domestique on verra aussi
de la livraison de colis qui se feront
par des robots des robots qui
distribueront du courrier tant qu'il
restera à distribuer des courriers mon
avis sa part et surtout qui va
disparaître en 2030 les cours y en aura
plus beaucoup on n'a plus beaucoup on
privilégiera les emails mais tout ce qui
nécessitera quand même un transport
physique de les robots le ferons et puis
on va pousser encore plus loin qu'à deux
derniers points le onzième point ça va
être le déploiement de l'ordinateur
quantique alors pour l'instant on en est
qu'au début il ya des promesses qui sont
faites sur l'arrivée potentielle
d'ordinateurs quantiques et encore
beaucoup de problématiques à résoudre
mais à l'horizon 2030 on devrait pouvoir
voir arriver les premiers ordinateurs
quantiques avec des capacités de calcul
complètement dingue et des usages qu'on
n'arrive pas encore à mesurer
aujourd'hui est 12ème point dirais c'est
vers l'infini et au delà la conquête
spatiale y aura des bases sur la lune
des bases par pays alors soit une grosse
base internationale où on vient
mutualisé soit alors chaque pays aurait
sa propre base alors on n'arriverait pas
tout de suite sur un partage des
territoires au niveau de la lune ça
arrivera bien bien bien bien plus tard
mais il y aurait une vie en continu sur
la lune telle qu'on peut la retrouver
aujourd'hui dans la station spatiale
internationale juste au dessus de nos
têtes faudra aller sur la lune ali
serait prêt clairement et puis y aurait
le début du tourisme spatial sur la lune
où on pourrait aller passer une nuit de
nuit cinq jours sur la lune alors ça
serait réservée aux très riches au
départ et puis après ça s'étendrait de
plus en plus pourquoi bien parce qu'il
faut venir financer tout ça et le
tourisme spatial pour les très riches
sans ramènerait le linge donc voilà
voyez pour ses 12 points on arrive à se
projeter sur 2030 on voit que le monde
va vraiment évolué on resterait sur la
base qu'on actuelle il y aurait des
points d'amélioration il y aurait des
choses intéressantes elles ce qui ne
serait peut-être pas je sais pas en tout
cas son sac ou dites moi vous ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire est ce que
vous êtes d'accord est ce que vous avez
une autre vision est ce que des choses
qui vous font peur parce que des fois
quand on regarde de loin devant quelque
chose qu'ils peuvent faire peur puis
dites moi si vous causez de se projeter
dans le monde en 2040 vous embrasse à
très bientôt ciao
[Musique]